Now that we know what a solution
is, let's think a
little bit about what it takes
to get a molecule to be
soluble into a solution
or into a solvent.
So let's say I start off with
a salt, and I'll do a little
side here, because in chemistry,
you'll hear the
word salt all the time.
Let me write it down: salt.
And in our everyday language,
salt is table salt.
It makes food salty,
or sodium chloride.
And this indeed is both a salt
from the Food Channel point of
view and from the chemistry
point of view, although the
chemistry point of view does not
care about what it does to
season your food.
The chemistry point of view, the
reason why it's called a
salt is because it's
a neutral compound
that's made with ions.
So we all know that this is
made when you take sodium.
Sodium wants to lose its one
electron in its valence shell.
Chloride really wants to
take it, so it does.
Chloride becomes a negative ion
and sodium is a positive
ion, and they stick to each
other really strongly because
this guy's positive now, and
this guy's negative after he
took away his electron.
Imagine your house is too small,
so you have to give
away your dog to someone who has
room for the dog, but now
you have to hang out at that
person's house all the time
because they have the
dog you love.
I don't know if that analogy
was at all appropriate.
But I think you get the idea.
A salt is just any compound
that's neutral.
The other common ones, potassium
chloride, you could
do calcium bromide, or I could
do a bunch of them, but these
are all salts.
And what we want to think about
is what happens when you
try to essentially dissolve
these salts in water.
So we know what water is
doing, liquid water.
So let me draw some
liquid water.
So if that's the oxygen and then
you have two hydrogens
that are kind of lumping off of
it, I'll draw it like that.
I'll draw a couple of them.
And then, of course, you have
another oxygen here.
Maybe the hydrogens are in this
orientation because the
hydrogen ends are attracted
through hydrogen bonds-- we've
learned this-- to the oxygen
ends because this has a slight
negative charge here, a slight
positive charge here.
These are the hydrogen
bonds that we've
talked so much about.
And maybe you have another
oxygen here and it's got its
hydrogens there and there.
You have some hydrogen
bonds there.
I could do another oxygen here,
and you can kind of see
the structure that forms,
although what I'm drawing,
this is actually more of a-- if
you were in a solid state,
this would be kind of
rigid and they would
just vibrate in place.
In the liquid state, they're
all moving around.
They're rubbing up against
each other, but they're
staying very close.
Actually, the liquid state for
water is actually the most
compact state for water.
Now, when you're dealing with
stuff like this-- these are
moving around, maybe this guy's
moving that way, that
guy's moving that way-- and you
want to dissolve something
like sodium chloride.
Sodium chloride's actually
quite a large molecule.
If you look at the Periodic
Table up here, oxygen is a
Period 2 element.
Hydrogen is very small.
We know when it gets into a
hydrogen bond with oxygen,
it's really just a proton
sitting out there because all
the electrons like to hang out
with the oxygen, while, say,
sodium and chloride, they're
considerably larger.
I won't go into the exact
molecular sizes, but maybe
sodium-- let's do sodium--
which actually, just as a
review, which is larger.
We know that it becomes smaller
as you go to the right
of the Periodic Table, so sodium
is quite a large atom,
while chloride is a good bit
smaller, but they're both
bigger than oxygen and a lot
bigger than hydrogen.
So let me draw that.
So sodium-- I'll do sodium
as a positive.
It's pretty big.
Maybe it looks like this.
Sodium is positive and then
you have the chloride.
The chloride I'll
do in purple.
They're still pretty big.
The chloride, it'll
look like this.
And what happens when you
put it into water, it
disassociates.
Even though these guys in
a solid state, they're
jam-packed to each other.
When you put it into water,
the positive cations are
attracted to the negative
partial charges on the oxygen
side of the water, and the
negative anions are attracted
to the positive sides
of the hydrogen.
But in order to get, for
example, this sodium ion into
the water, it has
to fit in there.
So, for example, I drew this as
a liquid initially, but if
this was a solid and you had
this structure, it would be
extremely difficult.
In fact, it would be next to
impossible to squeeze these
huge sodium ions in place
to make it soluble
into, say, solid ice.
And as even cold water, these
bonds are still going to be
pretty strong and they're
going to be just kind of
barely moving past each other
because there's not a lot of
kinetic energy.
So what you need to do is, the
warmer the water you have-- I
mean, you can fit it into cold
water, because at least cold
water has some give, but the
warmer the better, because you
have some kinetic energy, and
that essentially gives space.
Or it makes room for this sodium
ion that's entering in
to kind of bump its way into
a configuration that's
reasonably stable.
And a reasonably stable
configuration would look
something like this.
Sodium would look-- and then
you'd have a bunch of-- sodium
is positive.
It would be attracted to the
negative end of the water
molecules, so the oxygen end.
So it looks like that, the
oxygen end, and then the
hydrogen ends are going
to be pointing
in the other direction.
The hydrogen ends are going
to be on the other side.
And, of course, the chlorine
atom is going to be very
attracted to that other side, so
the chlorine atom might be
right over here.
So the chlorine atom might want
to hang out right here.
In order to get as much of the
sodium chloride into your
water sample, you want
to heat up the
water as much as possible.
Because what that does is it
allows these bonds to not be
taken as seriously and these
relatively huge atoms to kind
of bump their way in.
So, in general, if you think
about solubility of a solute
in water-- or especially if you
think of a solid solute,
which is sodium chloride-- into
a liquid solvent, then
the higher the temperature while
you're in the liquid
state, the more of the solid
you're going to be able to get
into the liquid, or you're going
to raise solubility.
So temperature goes up,
solubility goes up.
For example, if you were to take
some table salt, and you
could experiment with this.
It doesn't seem too dangerous
and not too expensive because
salt is reasonably cheap.
Keep putting it into
a glass, and at
some point it'll dissolve.
You could shake it a little
bit, just to make sure.
You could think about what's
happening at the molecular
level while you shake it and why
does that help to shake or
stir things?
But at some point, you're going
to end up with-- if this
is your glass of water, the salt
will keep going in there,
but at some point, you'll have
salt crystals at the bottom of
your glass.
At that point, your water is
saturated with salt at the
temperature that you're trying
to deal with it.
Now, right when you start seeing
that, if you were to
put it in the microwave or if
you were to heat it up, you
would see that even these guys
are able to be absorbed in the
water, and that's because the
extra kinetic energy from the
temperature is making it more
likely that these guys are
going to be able to bump out of
configuration for just long
enough for these guys
to bump in.
And just a little side note,
when you take these salts,
which are just ionic compounds
that are neutral, they're made
of ions, but they cancel
each other out.
When you put them in water,
these compounds by themselves
aren't normally-- when they're
in the solid state, they don't
normally conduct electricity.
Even though they're charged,
they're very closely stuck to
each other, so there's
not a lot of room
for movement of charge.
But once you disassociate them
in water or dissolve them in
water, now, all of a sudden,
you have these floating
charges in the water, and this
does conduct electricity, so
it becomes quite a reasonable
conductor of electricity.
So the general rule of thumb is,
if you're dealing with a
solid in a liquid solvent,
lowering the temperature will
decrease the solubility, because
it's harder to jam the
molecules in there, and
increasing the temperature
will increase the solubility.
But what about a gas?
What if you make some soda and
you want to dissolve some
carbon dioxide into, let's
say, water again?
So here, the way to think about
it when we did it with
salts, these are ionic
compounds.
They had some natural attraction
to the different
polar ends of the
water molecule.
But gases, for the most
part, do not have
strong attractive forces.
That's why they're gases,
especially at room
temperature.
They like to be free.
A gas, they have a good bit of
kinetic energy, but more
important, the bonds between
them, for example, in ideal
gases we talked about it, they
just have their London
dispersion forces.
They have very weak bonds, and
that's why at, say, the same
temperature and pressure that
water would be a liquid, a lot
of these gases are gases.
They jump away from each other
because they don't want to
touch each other.
Now, when you put this in
liquid, and this is at least
my intuition, so let's just say
this is a bunch of water
molecules here.
If you were to dissolve-- let's
say it's carbon dioxide.
You can ignore this
stuff up here.
If you were to dissolve carbon
dioxide in water-- so if you
were to dissolve this in water,
so those are some
carbon dioxide molecules.
I'm just drawing the whole
molecule as a circle.
What do these molecules
want to do?
It's natural state is a gas and
it is a gas at let's say
the standard pressure, so it
really wants to escape from
this water, but it just can't
do it that easily because
there's water molecules
all around it, right?
This guy right here, he might
want to bump out, but he's
surrounded by water molecules.
So what would help
him bump out?
Well, if you raise the average
kinetic energy of the system,
if you made all of these guys,
that these guys were moving
faster, and especially if the
carbon dioxide molecules
themselves had more kinetic
energy, then maybe
they could break out.
And as you have from personal
experience with Coke bottles,
you could also shake the system,
because if you shake
the system, it just moves
everything around enough that
these guys can escape.
So when you're dissolving
a gas inside of a liquid
solvent, when the solute is
a gas, it actually has the
opposite effect, that
rising temperature.
So when temperature goes up,
solubility goes down because
these guys want to escape.
They want to be free.
They want to be away from other
molecules and they want
to bounce around in open-- I
shouldn't use the word air--
in open space.
And so anything that lets the
system move around more,
they're going to go up.
And likewise, if temperature
goes down, solubility goes up.
The other factor, and it's not
as big of a factor when you
talk about a solid solute, but
when you talk about a liquid
solute-- let me just
do it again.
So those are the carbon dioxide
molecules and then you
have a bunch of water
molecules-- they should all be
the same size-- that
it's dissolved in.
I think you get the idea.
Pressure is also a big factor.
I already said that these guys,
their natural state is
to roam free.
They want to get out.
They want to somehow bounce
out of the water.
But if you have a really high
pressure up here-- just the
atmosphere up here has just
tons of molecules bouncing
really hard down on the surface
of our solution-- so
if there's just tons of
molecules bouncing really hard
off the surface, it'll
be harder for
anything to escape upwards.
And that's why, when you have
pressure going up, or at least
this is the intuition, when
pressure goes up, solubility
of a gas also goes up.
And this is for a gas.
So just the interesting thing
to remember is that when you
think about solubility, solids
do the inverse of gas.
Temperature is good for solid
solubility, right?
We said when you put salt or
sugar in water, it's good to
increase the temperature.
You'll be able put
more in there.
On the other hand, with a
gas, it's the opposite.
You want colder temperatures
to put more gas into the
solution, or you want higher
pressure to keep it-- at least
in the way my mind works-- from
escaping out the top.
Anyway, hope you found
that useful.